et bonsoir donc à thibaut plus chaud et
à julie creusot étudiants en master 2
professionnel métiers de la culture
administration culturels publics et
privés j'ai le titre complet comme ça
vous préparé ce rendez vous du mardi
gras à l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines c'est une première
c'est même plutôt surprenant parce que
du côté de l'université on évitait
peut-être ce genre de rendez-vous pour
éviter serait ce que les dérapages et
débordements et que ça reste calme sur
un site alors effectivement c'est la
première et non je pense qu'il avait
vraiment le désir de créer un événement
sur le site versailles parce qu'il y en
a très peu dans l'année donc le principe
était sur une journée de concentrer le
maximum d'animations que ce soit dans le
crous ou à l'extérieur donc dans les
différents bâtiments dans le parc donc
c'était vraiment non plutôt une volonté
une réelle volonté de la part de l'ue vs
cuit la direction de la vie étudiante il
ya plusieurs sortes de mer direction de
la vie étudiante voilà notre association
qui participe aussi l'italie
l'association rêve donc une association
qui est déjà basé sur le campus même de
versailles
donc il ya le master pro notre master
pro il ya la fac forcément de saint
quentin en yvelines on a après les
designs différents intervenants donc
la fanfare bond des ventes de bandes
d'herbe rase pardon qui fait partie donc
une fanfare de l'école nationale
d'architecturé de versailles
nous avons également
alors l'association cap dramé les bas
donc sept membres d'un groupe de
capoeira on a aussi donc un groupe d'une
association fa une compagnie de théâtre
al le théâtre d'improvisation qui est
guen production qui viennent donc
intervenir ils viennent d'en crous inter
du crous a mobilisé énormément d'acteurs
autour de cet événement la ville de
versailles de l'université où est le but
pourquoi célébrer mardi gras alors elle
aurait sans rendez vous de mardi gras le
choix s'est fait ben oui pourquoi pas
mardi gras comme les comme les plus
jeunes gens il va justement c'était la
base le 12 février il c'était le jour de
mardi gras on n'était pas forcément bien
de partir sur ce thème on s'est dit que
c'était quand même plus plus intéressant
et plus et plus drôle de le faire de
faire mardi gras nous de fêter carnaval
est a priori toute façon les étudiants
vont jouer le jeu puisqu'ils ont prévu
aussi dans chaque promo d'avoir un thème
de déguisements fait donc donc demain il
n'y aura pas de cours sur versailles ça
alors que roger staub et disait on va
essayer de faire en sorte qu' on n'est
pas non
ce ne sera pas dans pendant l'heure du
déjeuner voilà ouais c'est ça en fait
les manifestations se concentrer sur
entre 12h et 14h justement pour pas
gêner les cours comme c1 comme c'est un
début justement on commence comment ce
petit après on essaiera justement de
mobiliser plus de monde possible pour
faire ça vraiment sur une journée
complète et ce sera uniquement sur
versailles est ce que du côté de saint
quentin en yvelines que ce soit le site
vauban d'alembert ou sur le l'université
de droit également la faculté vous les
avez associés à la manifestation non là
c'était vraiment concentré sur le sur le
campus de versailles sur le campus
scientifique de versailles parce que
effectivement on n'a plus de lien avec
eux au final donc c'est une
manifestation qui est voué à faire
vraiment à faire bouger un peu le le
campus de versailles et surtout à faire
un lien finalement entre les deux
universités font pas ce cancer est
effectivement à côté de la faculté de
médecine y aura aussi quelque chose
d'organisé on reviendra toute façon
demain au cours de notre prochaine
édition sur ces différentes
manifestations verra c'est justement les
étudiants ont joué le jeu toute façon il
faudra qu'il se déguise aussi alors quel
est votre déguisement pouvoir mardi gras
voici quelques réponses
garde des enfants en fait je pense
qu'ils vont arriver à eux déguisés en
cow-boys loti sera en pirate et puis
comme tous les ans ils vont s'éclater
là-bas l'école quoi je pense que le
mardi gras a perdu 2 comment dirais-je
de son sel quoi moi je vois un mardi
gras une fête plus qu'en famille si vous
voulez dans les rues on se déguise et
tout ça ça ça n'existe plus oui
probablement va essayer de faire quelque
chose avec les enfants on va
voilà ils vont se déguiser ou autre oui
oui je vais fêter mardi gras bien sûr
avec mes petits-enfants on va acheter
des déguisements va faire des crêpes on
va et puis on va faire le tour du jardin
déguisé
il faut répondre à la question non je ne
serai pas déguiser en plateau de main
mais par contre quel sera votre
déguisement à chacun alors grande
question normalement moi ce sera une
star des années 80 voient la sébaste
c'est assez basse mais ça laisse
travailler dessus pendant la nuit en
fait exactement voilà je n'ai pas le
choix
on va essayer moi je vais essayer de
répondre à la tradition qui veut que
normalement pendant les carnavals des
fous justement les hommes s'habille en
femme donc je certainement au sexe était
bien évidemment puisque vous le savez je
vous dis tout dans l'oreillette on m'a
glissé voilà demain c'est vraiment de se
déguiser pour présenter l'émission mais
bien sûr mais bien sûr par rapport à ces
événements qui sont organisés est ce que
le public peut participer le public
extérieur c'est qu'il voudrait vous
rejoindre sur le campus éventuellement
de lycéens ou autre on sait il ya grève
demain justement dans les établissements
scolaires oui il a participé s'est pas
uniquement entre les étudiants plus on
est de fous plus on vit les moments
forts alors pour conclure quels sont les
moments elle va manquer à quelle heure
il faut venir pour l'avenir de 11h30
donc jusqu'à environ 14h30 et ses
pendants vraiment concentrés pendant
l'heure du déjeuner avec une fanfare
puis elle est surprise un peu prévu des
interventions collectives avec les
différents artistes mais je n'en dis pas
plus et donc dans le crous aussi pour le
théâtre et dans les différents bâtiments
pour la caméra et concours photos aussi
que l'association rêve justement donc un
concours photo du meilleur déguisement
et il ya une exposition une exposition
au sénat aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
exactement la scène deltell voilà qui
mise sur les carnavals nez sur le thème
des carnavals à découvrir à la décrire
exactement voilà pour ces différents
rendez vous que vous proposez bonne
chance pour le concours de demain cette
phase est effectivement vous nous direz
si ça a marché ou pas voilà donc pour ce
rendez vous autour de mardi gras demain
le sport dans quelques minutes c'est
anthony rech qui va me rejoindre mais
déjà après l université de versailles
saint quentin une autre école l école
nationale supérieure du paysage de
versailles journée portes ouvertes qui a
eu lieu ce samedi une autre est
programmée le 16 février
louis est élève en première année de bts
aménagement il est intéressé pour
intégrer l'école nationale supérieure du
paysage de versailles je vois qu'il ya
des maquette de choses qui ont été
faites
après c'est sympa c'est un moyen de
contrer par les deux personnes est d'en
savoir plus cette formation une journée
portes ouvertes pour savoir tout sur
cette école qui recrutent au niveau bac
+2 et forment aux métiers du paysage
chaque année 130 diplômés du paysage
passe par versailles dont 60 paysagiste
dplg nous sommes une école de conception
donc en fait nous avons un enseignement
qui se fait beaucoup en atelier à la
table comme vous pouvez le voir avec les
maquettes et dessins et c'est donc trop
intéressant de montrer ça à nos
visiteurs parce qu'au fond ce n'est pas
un enseignement académique les futurs
étudiants ont pu rencontrer les
enseignants visiter le potager du roi
sites emblématiques de leur formation et
surtout en savoir plus sur la
préparation aux concours dont les
inscriptions sont closes au 22 février
pour l'en tire vraiment à quoi ils
doivent s'attendre
ce qu'on fait tout le mond années et
leur donner des conseils pour le
concours l'école de versets dispose
également d'une antenne à marseille plus
spécialisés dans le paysage
méditerranéen
une autre journée portes ouvertes est
organisée samedi 16 février